***
Freunde der Strohhutbande!
Mit "Red" kommt nun endlich
ein neuer One-Piece-Film raus.
Erkennst du mich?
- Ruffy?
Es geht wieder um Ruffy,
den Anführer einer Piratenbande.
Der hat von einer Teufelsfrucht
gegessen
und so krasse Fähigkeiten bekommen.
Ruffy, was isst du da?
Spuk alles aus!
Was soll das?
Und ihr habt euch
so oft One Piece gewünscht.
Deshalb bringen wir euch
eine One-Piece-Folge.
Es geht
um meine Lieblings-Charaktere.
Und das sind die Crew-Mitglieder
mit krassen Fähigkeiten.
Wir klären, ob man mit einem Schwert
im Mund kämpfen könnte.
Kann man Menschen mit einem Stab
so hochheben und herumwirbeln?
Und wie viel Kraft bräuchte es,
um ein Hausteil so wegzukicken?
Und wir rechnen das nicht nur aus.
Wir machen auch noch
ein Experiment dazu.
Wir geben dem Rad
mal ordentlich Schmackes.
Also setzt die Segel
und lasst uns loslegen.
Es ist ein witziger Zufall,
dass jetzt One-Piece-"Red" rauskommt.
Ich habe grade
bei einer Cosplay-Convention
Marios Gavrilis kennengelernt.
Der ist Synchronsprecher eines der
Gegner in One Piece, von Katakuri.
Du hast es gewagt, mich zu stören
und beim Essen zu beobachten.
Das habe ich mir
nicht entgehen lassen
und habe ihn
für diese Folge mit ins Boot geholt.
Er gibt uns gleich mal
einen Überblick über One Piece.
In der Welt von One Piece
sucht die Strohhutbande,
eine Gruppe von Piraten unter
der Führung von Monkey D. Ruffy,
nach dem legendären Schatz
des Piratenkönigs Gold Roger.
Ruffy selbst hat
von der Gum-Gum-Frucht gegessen.
Deswegen
ist sein gesamter Körper wie Gummi.
Und
er hat übermenschliche Fähigkeiten.
Seine Crew besteht zum großen Teil
aus ganz normalen Menschen.
So zum Beispiel der Navigatorin
und Kartografin Nami,
dem Frauenhelden
und Schiffskoch Sanji
und dem berüchtigten Schwertkämpfer
Zorro.
Danke, Marios.
Diese 3 finde ich so spannend,
weil die nichts mit einem
fiktionalen Obstsalat zu tun haben.
Diese Teufelsfrüchte spielen
bei denen keine Rolle.
Die sind halt einfach so krass.
Und da frage ich mich immer gleich,
geht das?
Das finden wir jetzt raus.
Und wir starten mit ihm.
Zorro war, bevor er Ruffy
kennenlernte, Kopfgeldjäger.
Er ist der einzige
bekannte Schwertkämpfer,
der gleichzeitig
mit 3 Schwertern kämpft.
2 in den Händen
und eins zwischen den Zähnen.
Dafür trainiert er rund um die Uhr.
Der Typ hat wirklich Biss.
Und wie viel Biss Zorro für
diese Skills ganz genau braucht,
das klären wir jetzt.
Und zwar mit dem Mann,
mit dem wir schon Go-Karts über
Bananenschalen geschickt haben.
Der mir den Geruch
von verkohlten sauren Gurken
in die Nase gezaubert hat.
Und mit dem wir Explosionen
a la James Bond gezündet haben.
Der Physiker meines Vertrauens,
Henry.
Schön, dass du da bist.
- Freut mich.
Zorro kämpft ja mit einem Schwert
zwischen den Zähnen.
Ich glaube, da hatte jeder Zahnarzt
schon die Dollarzeichen in den Augen.
Unsere Zähne sind ziemlich robust.
Und nicht jeder verliert durch einen
Schlag automatisch einen Zahn.
Außerdem werden die
jeden Tag stark belastet.
Trotzdem nutzen die sich in
30 Jahren nur einen Millimeter ab.
Die sind schon ziemlich taff.
Es gibt sogar im Guinness-Buch
der Rekorde eine eigene Kategorie,
die heißt schwerstes Gewicht,
das je mit den Zähnen gehoben wurde.
Was schätzt du,
wie viel das ist?
Okay, man nimmt das so in den Mund
und hebt es hoch.
Wenn du dafür jeden Tag trainierst,
weiß nicht,
vielleicht eigenes Körpergewicht,
so 70, 80, 90 Kilo?
Fast, das schwerste Gewicht,
das je mit den Zähnen gehoben wurde,
das hat Walter Arfeuille
1990 in Paris gemacht.
Das waren 281,5 Kilogramm.
Das ist schon ordentlich
und zeigt ja aber,
was Zähne
für ein krasses Material sind.
Und am Ende natürlich
auch die Kiefer.
Aber die Kieferkraft allein
reicht nicht aus.
Stell dir vor,
das Schwert ist glitschig oder ölig.
Das würde
sofort aus dem Mund rutschen,
sobald Zorro einen Gegner trifft.
Da kann er so viel pressen,
wie er will.
Das heißt, wichtig ist, dass das
Schwert zwischen den Zähnen haftet.
Und dazu müssen wir uns
den Reibungskoeffizienten angucken.
Der gibt in unserem Fall
das Verhältnis der Reibungskraft
zu der Anpresskraft
zwischen den beiden Körpern an.
Und der ist abhängig
von den jeweiligen Materialien.
Dann münzen wir das
mal auf Zorro.
Nimm das Schwert,
ich nehme den Zorro.
Der Reibungskoeffizient
würde sich ergeben
aus dem Verhältnis der Kraft,
die jetzt von hier vorn
gegen das Schwert wirkt.
Das ist die Reibungskraft?
Genau,
und der Kraft, die er braucht,
um das Schwert
mit seinem Mund festzuhalten.
Wie kriegen wir den raus?
Wir könnten zuerst einmal
ins Tafelwerk schauen.
Da stehen verschiedene Werte drin,
zum Beispiel Gummi auf Asphalt
und solche Sachen.
Aber so Spezialfälle,
wie Banane auf Asphalt,
die findet man natürlich nicht.
Und auch Zahn auf Schwert
gibt es nicht.
Steht nicht drin, dann
ist es zu gar nichts zu gebrauchen.
Da hast du recht.
Aber es gibt in der Literatur
verschiedene Werte
aus der Dentalmedizin.
Zum Beispiel Zahn auf Metall, was
man etwa für Zahnspangen braucht.
Und diese Werte
liegen so ungefähr bei 0,3.
Der beißt aber nicht auf Metall.
Das wäre auch dumm,
direkt auf die Klingel zu beißen.
Sondern er beißt auf den Griff
und die sind immer so umwickelt.
Baumwollband, Seidenband.
Was heißt das dann
für den Reibungskoeffizienten?
Der Reibungskoeffizient
ist auf jeden Fall höher
als zwischen Zahn und Metall.
Jetzt sehen wir uns mal
einen Wert an zwischen Materialien,
die gut haften,
etwa Reifen auf Asphalt.
Da liegt der Wert bei 0,8.
Der ist vielleicht etwas zu hoch.
Ich würde jetzt einfach
die Mitte annehmen.
So bei 0,5 liegt ungefähr
der Reibungskoeffizient.
Okay, dann haben wir den.
Aber wir wollten ja
eine Kraft ausrechnen.
Was brauchen wir dafür noch?
Genau, wir wollen ausrechnen,
mit welcher Kraft er
die Zähne zusammenbeißen muss.
Diese Anpress-Kraft
nennen wir mal Beißkraft.
Zusätzlich braucht man
diesen Reibungskoeffizienten.
Den haben wir
gerade irgendwie angenommen.
Und wir brauchen die Kraft,
die auf das Schwert wirkt.
Wie wollen wir die nennen?
Die nennen wir Schwert-Kraft.
Come on!
Dann nehmen wir mal
so eine Standard-Zorro-Szene,
was er immer so macht.
Hier sehen wir ihn,
wie er mit seinen Schwertern
ein Gebäude
aus massiven Steinen zerschneidet.
Und diese Kraft, die das Gebäudeteil
jetzt auf das Schwert ausübt
das ist das, was wir als
Schwert-Kraft in der Formel haben.
Die können wir ausrechnen,
wenn wir das Material wissen,
aus dem dieser Häuserblock ist.
Ich habe mal angenommen,
das ist Granit.
Wir brauchen zusätzlich
die Maße dieser Klinge.
Wenn man das alles in so
eine bestimmte Formel einsetzt,
kommt eine Schwert-Kraft
von 3,6 Millionen Newton raus.
Okay, es sind wieder so hohe Werte.
Ich ahne,
wohin diese Berechnung führt.
Gut, dann haben wir jetzt
die Schwert-Kraft.
Darüber können wir
die Beißkraft ausrechnen.
Genau, die kriegen wir raus,
wenn wir die Schwert-Kraft
durch unseren Reibungskoeffizienten
von 0,5 teilen.
Das ergibt einen Wert
von über 7 Millionen Newton.
Das ist mal wieder
ein exorbitanter Wert.
Ordne uns den mal ein.
Okay, die maximal beim
menschlichen Kiefer gemessene Kraft
liegt bei 4.300 Newton.
Die stärksten Kiefer aller Zeiten
hatte der Megalodon.
Das ist so ein Vorfahre
vom Weißen Hai.
Der kommt auf eine Beißkraft
von 180.000 Newton.
In dieser Szene hier,
da presst die berühmte hydraulische
Presse ein Stück Stahl zusammen.
Und das macht die
mit 900.000 Newton.
Das heißt, Zorro müsste das 8-Fache
dieser Kraft aufbringen,
um das Schwert zu halten.
Dann können wir
an dieser Stelle festhalten,
er ist auf keinen Fall
ein normaler Mensch.
Er ist eine richtige Maschine.
Und er hätte aber
ein Problem damit.
Sagen wir mal, er kriegt das hin
mit seinem krassen Training,
diese Beißkraft zu erreichen.
Dann würde er bei diesem
8-fachen Wert der Hydraulikpresse
ja sein eigenes Stahlschwert
komplett zerbeißen.
Oh ja.
Sanji hat nur eine Schwäche, Frauen.
Wenn er nicht gerade wieder
einer Dame zu Füßen liegt,
ist er ein beinharter Kämpfer.
Weil ihm als Koch seine Hände heilig
sind, kämpft er nur mit den Füßen.
Egal, ob Holz, Stein oder Gegner.
Sanji kickt nicht nur alles weg, er
sieht dabei auch besonders cool aus.
Sehr lässig.
Und weißt du, was das Beste ist?
- Nein.
Wenn wir jetzt
eine Szene raussuchen wollen,
können wir die nehmen,
über die wir gerade gesprochen haben.
Zorro macht nämlich die
ganze Vorarbeit mit seinem Schwert.
Und dann kommt Sanji und vollendet.
Gute Teamarbeit auf jeden Fall.
Aber Himmel,
ich habe mir gleich gedacht,
Knochen auf Stein, das tut weh.
Jeder, der sich mal einen Fuß
am Tischbein gestoßen hat,
der weiß,
allein das macht schon Schmerzen.
Das ist kompliziert, oder?
Stimmt, ist mega unangenehm.
Aber es gibt in der realen Welt
auch schon Beispiele,
wo Menschen Steine zerstören.
Etwa beim Karate,
und da kriegen es sogar Kinder hin.
Ja, aber hier will Sanji
diesen Häuserblock rauskicken.
Er will also beschleunigen,
nicht zerstören.
Und da können wir einfach
die Formel F gleich einmal A,
also Masse
mal Beschleunigung benutzen.
Das ist unsere Lieblingsformel, da
müssen wir nur noch Werte einsetzen.
Und ich habe
schon mal im Fandom geschaut.
Der Gegner, den wir in dieser Szene
sehen, ist 67 Meter hoch.
Und wenn wir den
als Referenz nehmen,
dann kriegen wir raus,
dass diese Häuserblocks
ungefähr 12 Meter hoch sind,
21 Meter lang und breit,
und er ist innen hohl.
Und diese Wandstärke
ist ungefähr 1 Meter.
Damit können wir jetzt
die Masse ausrechnen von dem Block.
Die ergibt sich aus der Dichte
des Materials mal dem Volumen.
Und das Volumen
kriegen wir einfach raus.
Das ist Länge mal Breite mal Höhe.
Dann müssen wir noch
über die Wandstärke
diesen inneren Block rausrechnen.
Und es ergibt sich ein Volumen von
diesem Block von 960 Kubikmetern.
Zusammen mit der Dichte von Granit
ergibt sich eine Masse von
2.600 Tonnen für diesen Block.
Okay, dann brauchen wir
jetzt noch die Beschleunigung.
Die kriegen wir
aus dem zurückgelegten Weg
geteilt durch die
dafür benötigte Zeit ins Quadrat.
Ich habe jetzt mal
die Wiedergabegeschwindigkeit
des Videos ganz niedrig gestellt.
Da sieht man, dass der Block,
seine Breite, also die 21 Meter,
in ungefähr
0,25 Sekunden zurücklegt.
Zusammen
mit der Masse von 2.600 Tonnen
ergibt das eine Kraft
von 870 Millionen Newton.
Wieder ein Riesenwert!
Und ich erinnere mich,
in der letzten Folge
haben wir über Menschen gesprochen,
die so krasse Kräfte ausüben.
Ja, da ging es um Saitama.
Und der hat ja Superkräfte.
Aber selbst für den
wären 870 Millionen Newton
schon eine echte Hausnummer.
Das stimmt.
Und da sieht man,
dass bei solch großen Kräften
da tendenziell mehr zerstört wird,
statt einfach so weggekickt.
Wenn wir das noch mal zurückholen
in die reale Welt,
da können wir mal einen Rücksprung
in die One-Punch-Man-Folge machen.
Da haben wir euch
Oliver Schabe vorgestellt,
zweifacher Schlagkraft-Weltmeister
und Weltrekordhalter.
Und der kickt
mit gerade mal 12.000 Newton.
Schwach, und Sanji
bringt nämlich 70.000-mal so viel.
Aber selbst das schafft er
nicht durch hartes Training.
Ja, Sanji ist wahrscheinlich
doch irgendwann mal
in den großen Topf
mit den Teufelsfrüchten gefallen.
Nami ist die Navigatorin
und Kartografin der Strohhutbande.
Kämpfe bestreitet sie eher selten.
Wenn sie doch kämpfen muss, verlässt
sich Nami nicht auf ihre Stärke,
sondern auf ihren Klima-Taktstock.
Mit ihm
kann sie starke Attacken ausführen,
ihre Gegner buchstäblich
auf den Kopf stellen.
Dieser Klima-Taktstock
ist eine ziemlich coole Erfindung.
Aber kann der Nami
wirklich dabei helfen,
Leute nicht nur hochzuheben,
sondern tatsächlich
so durch die Luft zu wirbeln?
Das finden wir jetzt raus
mit diesem hochwissenschaftlichen
Bierkasten.
Warum haben wir den?
Versuche den mal hochzuheben,
wie du es normal machen würdest.
So halt.
Relativ nah am Körper
mit den Armen und so, super.
Jetzt versuche ihn anzuheben
mit ausgestreckten Armen.
Also weiter weg.
Und?
- Ja, es ist schwerer.
Genau.
Es ist deswegen schwerer,
weil die Gewichtskraft zusammen
mit deinem ausgestreckten Arm
ein Drehmoment ergibt.
Dieses Drehmoment ist
das Produkt aus Kraft und Hebelarm.
Je länger der Hebelarm ist,
desto größer ist bei einer
bestimmten Kraft das Drehmoment.
Das heißt, Nami macht es sich
schwerer mit dem Stab.
Genau, aber lass es uns
einfach mal ausrechnen.
Wir gehen noch mal
zu dir und dem Bierkasten.
Hier wirken 3 Drehmomente.
Einmal das Drehmoment
durch das Gewicht des Bierkastens.
Dann das Drehmoment durch
das Gewicht deines Oberkörpers.
Die versuchen,
den Oberkörper nach links zu kippen.
Damit das nicht passiert,
wirkt jetzt noch ein Drehmoment
durch deine Rückenmuskulatur.
Die versucht,
dich wieder nach rechts zu kippen.
Insgesamt muss das Drehmoment
durch deine Rückenmuskulatur
genauso groß sein wie die beiden
anderen Drehmomente zusammen,
damit du nicht umfällst.
Da kann man das also gleichsetzen.
Wenn man das jetzt für Nami
ausrechnen will
braucht man sicher ein paar Werte.
Dazu ersetzen wir dich
erst mal durch Nami.
Ich habe jetzt hier mal halbwegs
realistische Werte für die Abstände,
also für die Hebelarme angelegt.
Da schätze ich den langen Hebel zu
ihrer Gegnerin auf 110 Zentimeter.
Zusätzlich braucht man jetzt noch
das Gewicht von Namis Oberkörper.
Die wiegt laut Fandom-Wiki
50 Kilogramm.
Typischerweise macht der Oberkörper
62% des gesamten Körpergewichts aus,
macht bei Nami
insgesamt 31 Kilogramm.
Jetzt müssen wir den Bierkasten
durch ihre Gegnerin,
die Miss Double Finger, ersetzen,
Die schätze ich auf 70 Kilogramm.
Diese ganzen Sachen setzen wir jetzt
in unsere Formel ein.
Hier müssen wir noch,
um die Kräfte auszurechnen,
die Massen mit der Erdbeschleunigung
multiplizieren.
Wenn wir das alles machen,
kommen wir auf eine Kraft
von ungefähr 15.000 Newton.
Die muss
ihre Rückenmuskulatur aufbringen,
um Miss Double Finger hochzuheben.
Selbst der Wert
ist noch ein bisschen unterschätzt,
weil,
sie steht ja ein bisschen schräg.
Das habe ich jetzt vernachlässigt.
Aber selbst 15.000 Newton
ist recht viel.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass sie
die einfach am Stab hochhält,
sondern der Stab dreht sich ja.
Da muss ich an dieses Video denken
von unseren YouTube-Kollegen
vom Kanal Veritasium.
Der Derek
hat auch ein superschweres Gewicht.
Und das kann er scheinbar
mühelos da in der Luft halten,
weil er dieses Gewicht
vorher in Drehung versetzt.
Das sieht erst mal krass aus
und man würde erwarten,
dass das Gewicht
einfach nach unten kippt.
Aber macht es nicht,
weil es rotiert.
Diesen Effekt nennt man Präzession.
Das hat damit zu tun,
dass das Drehmoment,
verursacht durch die Gewichtskraft,
die Richtung des Drehimpulses
dieses Gewichts ändert.
Ganz schön viele Begriffe heute.
Nimm mich noch mal ein bisschen mit.
Okay, erinnerst du dich
an die Wonder-Woman-Folge?
Ja.
- Cool.
Da ging es um den Impuls.
Da hatten wir
das Newtonsche Pendel.
Der Impuls ist eine Erhaltungsgröße,
der bleibt immer gleich
und wird weitergegeben.
Genau, der bleibt solange gleich,
solange keine Kraft wirkt.
Aber wenn jetzt eine Kraft wirkt,
ändert die den Impuls.
Da habe ich das erste coole
Experiment des Tages mitgebracht.
Und zwar diesen Bierdeckel.
Wenn der Bierdeckel
hier in meiner Hand liegt,
dann hat er keinen Impuls,
er ist in Ruhe.
Wenn durch meine Hand eine Kraft
auf den Bierdeckel nach oben wirkt,
wird sich sein Impuls
genau in diese Richtung ändern.
Er wird nach oben hin schneller,
bekommt jetzt einen Impuls.
Und das, was wir jetzt hier für
eine gerade Bewegung gesehen haben,
können wir einfach auf
eine Rotationsbewegung übertragen.
Dazu brauche ich deine Hilfe, denn
ich habe noch ein Experiment mit.
Hey, what is he doing?
Willkommen
in Henrys Fahrradwerkstatt.
Ich habe hier
eine Fahrradfelge mitgebracht
und sie an einer Seite aufgehangen.
Wenn wir die jetzt einfach
hochheben und fallen lassen,
passiert halt erst mal nix.
So weit, so unspektakulär.
Aber jetzt ...
Halt die mal drüben fest.
Wir geben dem Rad
mal ordentlich Schmackes.
So, und jetzt lass mal los.
Es steht in der Luft.
Es ist so irre.
Es ist so irre!
Siehst du, es dreht sich,
es fällt nicht nach unten.
Halte es mal fest.
- Warum dreht sich das?
Das Rad dreht sich zwar nach vorne,
aber der Drehimpuls
zeigt dazu senkrecht.
Wenn du das loslässt, erzeugt
die Gewichtskraft ein Drehmoment,
das aber nicht nach unten zeigt,
sondern komischerweise nach hinten.
Okay.
Wie bei dem Bierdeckel ändert das
Drehmoment die Richtung des Impulses
genau in diese Richtung.
Und das nennt man Präzession.
Deswegen kippt sie nicht nach unten,
sondern folgt permanent
dieser Drehrichtung.
Genau.
Okay, aber das ist ja mega-cool,
weil das ist ja genau das,
was Nami macht mit ihrem Stock.
Und das haben wir
auch bei Derek im Video gesehen.
Ja, durch die Rotation
wird das Ganze leichter.
Es ist immer noch so,
dass es so wäre,
als würde Nami ihre Gegnerin
da am ausgestreckten Arm hochheben.
Was zugegebenermaßen
immer noch schwer ist.
Aber dieser Taktstock würde ihr
beim Heben auf jeden Fall helfen.
Das heißt, die Rotation ersetzt
die komplette Länge des Stockes.
Genau.
Das ist ziemlich cool, weil es
erst mal eine geile Erfindung ist,
die sich ein physikalisches Phänomen
zunutze macht.
Im Endeffekt
hilft sie wirklich dabei,
deine Gegner hochzuheben,
wenn du sie nah am Körper hältst.
Genau.
Ich muss zugeben, ich fühle mich
jetzt ein bisschen schwach davon.
Ja, ich mich auch.
Dafür sind wir alle
ein bisschen schlauer geworden.
Vielen Dank fürs Erklären, Henry.
- Sehr gern.
Und Riesendank an Marios, der uns
diese geilen Einspieler gemacht hat.
Der macht gute Videos
bei Instagram und TikTok.
Wenn ihr mehr davon sehen wollt,
schaut bei ihm vorbei.
Link packe ich in die Infobox.
Ich würde mich freuen,
wenn ihr einen Kommentar da lasst
und der Folge
einen Daumen nach oben gebt.
Aber vergesst auf keinen Fall,
diesen Kanal hier zu abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Da sehen wir uns bald wieder.
- Ich freue mich drauf.
Bis dann.
- Tschau.
Wenn ihr mehr Bock auf Physik habt
und auf Henry
dann schaut mal
in unsere Physik-Playlist rein.
Da taucht er ganz häufig mit auf.
Und weil wir heute
harte Kicks besprochen haben,
die gibt es auch hier unten.
Copyright MDR 2022